from the logs we know that we have the
right forecast data and it's in the
right format that we want as an array of
strings so it's finally time to update
the UI sync back on how async tasks are
able to pass data back on to the main
thread you can hit ctrl o to see the
list of available methods we can
override an async task if you click on
any of them it will be pre-populated in
the code for you then you can update
array adapter with the new data that was
retrieved by the async task as a hint
you can make the forecast adapter be a
global variable that way you can access
it from within the fetchweathertask
make sure that this is not a static
class otherwise you won't be able to
access the member variable from the
forecastfragment
then go ahead and compile and build the
app when you run it and you hit the
refresh button you should see a week's
worth of weather data for your location
once it's working you can remove the
verbose log statements so you don't
clutter the logs as you're working on
this code if you see an unsupported
operation exception make sure that when
you are creating the fake data that when
you initialize arrayadapter you passed
in a list of strings and not an array
that way you can call the clear method
or the add method on this list
collection